from blistering hot deserts to deep blue
oceans from frozen ponds too swampy
wetlands animal species have adapted and
evolved in unique ways
let's take a look deep inside these
distinctive animals and learn what
adaptations they've picked up in order
to call these harsh landscapes home at
first glance a kangaroo's pouch looks
like nothing but a built-in baby sling
but if you peeked inside you'd see it's
far more complex than a simple pocket it
has to be because the Joey inside is not
your average baby an adult male red
kangaroo can stand over one-and-a-half
meters tall and weigh 90 kilograms
that's larger than a grown man but the
newborn start out the size of jellybeans
they're blind deaf and hairless to boot
after all they only spend 33 days inside
their mom before births that's like a
human having a baby when she's 2 months
pregnant so the underdeveloped roo isn't
ready to face the harsh Australian
wilderness that's where the pouch comes
in it's a pocket of skin that acts like
a second womb giving the Joey a safe
cozy environment to grow and like a
pregnant belly the pouch can stretch to
fit the baby as it gets bigger it's
lined with powerful but flexible muscles
and ligaments to keep the Joey safe mom
can tighten those muscles to shut the
pouch flush against her body just like
pulling a drawstring bag closed and it
will need the extra space because over
the course of eight months that bean
sized baby will reach the size of a
large house cat that's thousands of
times its birth weight that rapid growth
is thanks to the pouches for nipples
which spout milk that contains germ
fighting antibodies to keep the little
roo from getting sick but that's just
the start you see the nutrient levels
change to meet the baby's needs as it
ages
for example sulfur a major building
block of hair Peaks around three months
in that's the same time the baby starts
growing fur the best part
mom can produce multiple types of milk
at the same time each squirting from its
own nipple so she can suckle two babies
in different age groups simultaneously
another special feature about the
kangaroo pouch is that it's lined with
sweat glands that release antimicrobial
substances which help protect the baby
Roos from harmful viruses bacteria and
parasites but there's one more way that
pouches design keeps the Joey's safe
it's totally hairless and that
skin-to-skin contact
keeps the baby warm and cozy basically
it's the ultimate nursery but nothing
lasts forever eventually the Joey will
need to leave the pouch at about five
months old it pokes its head out and a
month later it takes its first tentative
steps into the world there it will
explore for a few short seconds before
hightailing at home but as it gets older
and bolder it stays out longer until
eight months in it's ready to leave the
nest
well the pouch for good
what would you do for the power to fly
how about shedding your skin and
dissolving your own muscles now believe
it or not that gruesome process is how
caterpillars earn their wings here's
what you might not know about what's
inside a caterpillars cocoon contrary to
popular belief this is not a cocoon only
certain moths built cocoons which are
like a silky sleeping bag that covers
the insect this on the other hand is
what's called a chrysalis
it's not a sac or a pouch it's actually
the caterpillars own body when it's time
for the transformation to begin the
caterpillars body ramps up production of
a hormone called Ekta zone and that
causes it to cast off its outer coating
sort of like how a snake sheds its skin
and underneath is a hard shell similar
to the exoskeleton of a beetle after
that life for the little caterpillar
gets easy first it releases enzymes
called caspases these rip apart and
dissolve cells in its muscles digestive
system and other organs but the enzymes
don't quite liquefy all of the
caterpillar they leave key structures
intact like breathing tubes at the same
time specialized cells called imaginal
discs start waking up before the
chrysalis stage these discs were kept
dormant by a series of hormones in the
caterpillars body but once the
transformation begins those hormone
levels take a nosedive giving these
discs the opportunity to do what they do
best build a butterfly you see each disc
contains the genetic recipe to form a
different adult body part starting from
the inside out after one week the
digestive system of the butterfly is
well on its way
and by day 16 the adults legs wings eyes
and mouth are all present and in working
order now two weeks is a remarkably
short time for all of this to happen
since each imaginal disc starts out with
only about 50
sells and must multiply those into
thousands just to form a single wing and
if you checked out the chrysalis around
day 16 you might even be able to see
those brilliantly colored wings because
for some species their chrysalis turns
transparent in their final days of
metamorphosis now fully formed it's time
to hit the road the chrysalis splits
open down the center and the butterfly
escapes meanwhile a reddish liquid
spills out that's all the waste the
butterfly in a caterpillar produced
during its stay once its wings expand
and harden it's ready to mate pollinate
and slurp nectar to its heart's desire
but one of the most interesting parts of
all research suggests that butterflies
and moths can remember their caterpillar
days in one study researchers trained
moth caterpillars to associate an odor
with an electric shock
so whenever the larvae smelled it they'd
move away but even after they
transformed into adult moths they still
avoided the scary smell it makes you
wonder what else they could recall from
their younger days when it comes to
deadly predators plants generally don't
come to mind after all they're typically
at the bottom of the food chain but the
Carolinas are home to one vicious
vegetable the Venus flytrap using its
famous trap it can catch prey faster
than you can blink but what happens next
inside a Venus flytrap
funny thing about venus flytraps they
don't usually trap flies in fact winged
insects only make up about 5% of their
diet and we really ought to be calling
it the Carolina spider trap because
that's really it's only found in the
Carolinas and actually a little piece of
the Carolinas and in most lead spiders
and and in ants but of course regardless
of species that bug is going to have a
bad day it all starts when the victim
one
into the trap possibly lured by the
bright red hue or fragrant scent or
maybe they're just unlucky we think the
spider is mostly just blunder the trap
itself looks like an open mouth it's
made of two pads attached to a hinge on
each one of those pads there are usually
three little trigger hairs in a kind of
a triangle and those trigger hairs are
very very sensitive to being disturbed
the first time a spider knocks into a
hair it sets off an electrical signal
sort of like the electrical currents in
your brain that signal starts the
countdown if the bug escapes within 20
to 30 seconds nothing else happens that
way the plant doesn't waste energy but
if the bug brushes against another hair
snap in just a hundred milliseconds
about four times faster than you can
blink the trap slams shut then the trap
rapidly goes from convex to concave on
each side and the long little spikes on
the rims of the pads interlock to form
kind of a cage now of course the spider
isn't happy with this turn of events so
it tries to escape which is exactly what
the plant wants the more the spider
struggles the more it knocks into the
trigger hairs
the tighter the trap closes and after an
hour or two the trap locks completely
cells on the edges of the pads secrete
moisture which glues the edges together
to form an airtight seal suddenly that
trap isn't a mouse anymore it's a
stomach digestive juices flood into the
closed compartment dissolving the
spiders soft organs and the traps lining
sucks up that nutrient-rich slushie
after about a week all that's left is an
empty husk the spiders exoskeleton next
the trap reopens and the husk tumbles
out the trap is now ready for its next
meal but bugs aren't the only food that
trap capture
just like leaves on other plants the
trap surface contains a green pigment
that lets it convert the sun's energy
into sugar through a process called
photosynthesis
so then why bother with the bugs
well venus flytraps live an acidic
waterlogged soil that doesn't have many
nutrients so instead of slurping up
nitrogen and phosphorous through its
roots it needs to borrow some from the
bugs that explains why it shares its
home with other hungry carnivorous
plants like pitcher plants and sundews
which could only mean one thing
North Carolina is not a fun place to be
a bug if there's one thing you know
about pufferfish it's that they can do
this when aggravated by a predator they
you know puff up some puffers like the
porcupine fish become a bonafide spiked
ball moving through the water seemingly
out of control but if you peer inside a
puffer you'll learn that puffing up
isn't the only trait that makes these
fish one of the most threatening
creatures in the sea
contrary to what it looks like
puffer fish are not like balloons
because what's normally inside them
isn't air its water what they do is they
actually take water into their mouths in
a big mouthful of water and then they
pump it down into their stomach that's
Elizabeth Brainard a biologist and
pufferfish expert at Brown University
and they do that anywhere 10 or 15 times
pump pump pump pump pump pump until they
inflate completely and then they hold it
and they'll just be a big spiny ball and
as you might expect this requires some
pretty sophisticated biology starting
with the stomach it's made of dozens of
tiny folds kind of like an accordion
these folds are important because when
the stomach fills up with water it can
expand without rupturing and puffer fish
expand a lot up to three times their
size that's like if an average human man
could
flate his waist to a circumference of
three meters but there is a drawback to
these amazing skills
brainerd suspects that puffer fish
stomachs have actually lost the ability
to digest food which means their
intestines have to do all the work you
know given the apparent importance of
this defense mechanism they've given up
the advantages of having a stomach where
some digestion can start but the stomach
it's just one of many bizarre features
inside a puffer
for example they have specialized
muscles that you won't find in most
other fish some in their mouth which
pump all that water into their stomach
some in their esophagus to seal off
their stomach like a drain plug once
it's full and some in the base of their
bellies which contracts to squeeze out
water when they're ready to deflate but
what you won't find inside is even more
bizarre
there are couple characters that are
really helpful in their ability to puff
up and one of those is that they don't
have any ribs and another one is they
don't have any pelvis in other words
puffers are essentially missing bones
and that's a good thing because
otherwise they'd get in the way of
inflation in fact according to Brainard
if it weren't for these missing bones
pufferfish would probably have never
evolved this way in the first place and
that would be a shame since puffing up
really is a good defense consider one
old study in which researchers watched
birds go fishing
the birds caught 11 pufferfish but they
dropped nearly half of them because the
fish started to inflate but what's more
surprising is that the birds left with
empty beaks might have been the lucky
ones because puffers have another more
potent defense up their sleeves their
bodies are laced with a neurotoxin
called tetrodotoxin it's up to 1,200
times more poisonous than cyanide so
poisonous that one puffer fish can kill
30 adult humans so poisonous that
puffers are reportedly the second most
poisonous vertebrae in
world which is why it's also surprising
that us humans we actually eat them
that's right in Japan pufferfish is
actually a delicacy called fugu which
only trained chefs can prepare and
considering that these fish are
basically spiked balls filled with
poison and we're still serving them in
restaurants they must be seriously
delicious if you're hiking pretty much
anywhere in the US this is one sound you
don't want to hear the warning of a
rattlesnake
now just because a rattlesnakes tail
sounds like a built-in maraca doesn't
mean it works like one there are no
beads rattling about in here so what's
really going on inside if you opened up
a rattlesnakes rattle and shook it
absolutely nothing would fall out after
all
so rattlesnake rattles are hollow that's
herpetologist Tim Colston
he says the secret to that rattling
sound comes from the shell itself it's
made of keratin the same hard substance
as your fingernails the keratin is
arranged in a chain of interlocking
rings which are hooked together by tiny
grooves along their edge now watch what
happens to those rings when Colston
shakes the rattle when ever I shake them
very fast they bump together producing
the sound because the rattle is hollow
inside sound waves can bounce off the
walls and echo the same way shouting in
a cave amplifies the sound and the
bigger the cave or hollow rings in this
case the more amplification so it's a
louder the rattle but a big hollow
chamber can't get the job done on its
own that's where the tail muscles come
in rattlesnakes are equipped with three
powerful shaker muscles at the base of
their spine those can contract so fast
they vibrate the rattle up to 90 times a
second for comparison the human eye
blinks 15 to 20 times a minute
by vibrating so quickly the rattle makes
a sound that hits between these specific
frequencies
and it just so happens that that range
is best heard by mammals it turns out
that tail is custom designed to make
predators like bears raccoons and
weasels listen up
unfortunately snake 'lets yes that's
what baby snakes are called don't have
this warning signal whenever a
rattlesnake is born it just has a single
button it looks similar to the one I
don't know if you can see that's on the
end here without a second button to
clack against the baby rattle can't make
any noise
but every time they shed their skin they
add another button to the base of the
rattle which grows into the segment
above sort of like the structure of a
Russian stacking doll the rattle will
keep growing until snap just like your
fingernails those rattles are pretty
fragile and they can break off if they
get too long in fact the rattles rarely
make it past eight to ten rings before
snapping off luckily snakes shed their
entire lives so the rattle will grow
back good as new
which is good news for you hikers
because that handy tail can mean the
difference between an exciting day on
the trail and a painful trip to the
hospital did you know that camels used
to live in the Arctic tundra yes
camels walking around on ice and snow
it's true in 2013 scientists announced
they'd discovered mummified leg bones on
Ellesmere Island which belonged to the
ancestors of modern day one and two
humped camels in fact in during the
frigid Tundra is how scientists think
camels got their iconic hump in the
first place because what's inside helps
them survive in an age when many other
animals were wiped out what's inside a
camel hump is fat and a lot of people
think it's water but it's certainly not
it's fat and it nourishes them when
they're on wrong journey that's right
fat each hump can store up to 36 killer
of it which can sustain the camel for
weeks or even months without food and
that sort of adaptation was especially
important 3.5 million years ago during
the middle of an ice age when the
ancestors to modern camels were hanging
out in the Arctic tundra talking about
the Ice Age when a lot of mammals were
killed during that time and yet the
camel managed to survive by developing
this emergency food system if you like
some eventually camels migrated across
the Bering Strait into regions of Asia
and Africa where the fat inside their
humps help them adapt yet again this
time to the blistering hot temperatures
of deserts like the Gobi and Sahara you
see camels are one of the only animals
in the world that store all their fat in
one spot and that's useful for keeping
cool in a hot climate because heat can
escape faster from the rest of their
body which helps them maintain a lower
body temperature compare that to other
mammals like humans who store fat all
over making it a lot harder to stay cool
today cam will still use the fat in
their humps as a food reserve but
they're not the only ones in extreme
circumstances the Turkana tribe in Kenya
for example will eat camel fat to
survive they suffer a lot from periods
of extreme drought and I have seen these
people there be very very short of food
and this is difficult to believe but
it's true slit open the top of a camel's
hump take out the fat for their own
consumption and then put the top of the
hump back on again but don't worry the
camel makes a full recovery and
instances are rare but this practice has
started to generate some buzz around
camel fat as a new superfood turns out
camel fat is loaded with fatty acids
vitamins and minerals desert farms a
company that sells camel fat says that
just one tablespoon contains 40 percent
of your daily vitamin b12 needs and
three times the amount of oleic acid
then coconut oil a superfood staple and
since all that nutritious fat is what
fills the hump out when a camel fasts
for long periods its hump can actually
go limp gradually diminishing size but
it's been in a very harsh environment
they go completely limp and flop over
the side of the camels backbone now
since we know that fat is what makes up
the hump instead of water I got us
wondering how do camels stay hydrated in
such dry climates well they have unique
blood cells that run throughout their
entire body including a few in the hump
itself these blood cells are extremely
elastic perfect for holding a lot of
water
camels can drink up to 115 liters in
about 10 minutes expanding the cells up
to two hundred and forty percent in the
process there are capillaries throughout
its body and when it has a drink
it drinks and drinks and drinks and it
swells up and it looks as though it's
pregnant if that's not impressive enough
the wild camel of China has even been
known to survive on salt water so
whether it's surviving the harsh desert
heat weeks without food and water or
even the Canadian Arctic the camel is
one of the best adapters in the animal
kingdom and that's in large part thanks
to its iconic
hump at first glance a fire ant hill or
mound as its properly called
looks impossibly small and yet a colony
of up to 250 thousand ants call it home
but here's the secret that mound is just
the tip of an enormous iceberg so let's
take a closer look at what's inside an
anthill the mound is really the top of
an enormous underground structure the
nest which is basically a giant nursery
a nice cozy place to raise babies a lot
of babies their mother the Queen roams
around the nest while laying 1,500 eggs
a day
now all those baby ants need to live in
a narrow temperature range to grow so
that nest
sports temperature controlled
and it does so without the help of an AC
unit the secret is in the design the
nest is arranged like an ice-cream cone
at the top you have the mound the
ice-cream as it were because it's above
the surface it warms from the heat of
the Sun so the babies can snuggle up in
toasty chambers network throughout the
mound but they can't stay there all day
or they'd get too hot that's where the
cone part of the ice cream cone comes in
the mound is connected to several
vertical shafts that plunge up to 2
meters beneath the ground that's taller
than most humans throughout the day
adult ants ferry the babies up and down
the shafts chasing that perfect
temperature for their young charges the
nest also sports dozens of tapering
tunnels that branch off from these main
shafts these connect to small chambers
where the ants rest eat and feed the
babies until it's time to move the
little ones once again now there's one
more type of tunnel inside the nest but
only a few ants ever use it you see
someone needs to find food for the rest
of the colony but running around outside
the nest is dangerous business
that's where forager tunnels come in
these are a couple of horizontal
passages buried just a few centimeters
from the surface but they run throughout
the entire territory which can cover up
to 185 square meters of land by
scurrying through these passageways the
scouts can stay underground as long as
possible but unfortunately the nest and
all its roads can't protect the ants
from every threat it turns out all sorts
of critters sneaked inside fire ant
nests and while many of them are
actually harmless others are horrible
houseguests for example beetles burrow
into the nest and devour the eggs and
larvae but invaders aren't the only
threat to the colony occasionally
clueless humans or major floods disturb
the nest and when that happens the fire
ants have only one option leave once a
year on average the colony will move out
and build an entirely new nest from
scratch and best of all they only need a
few
days to do it that's right practically
overnight meters upon meters of tunnels
can pop up in your yard and all you'll
notice is a tiny mound a turtle shell is
as much a part of its body as our
ribcage is of ours in fact it is their
ribcage and their spine and their
vertebrae and their sternum basically a
turtle skeleton is inside out and just
like you can't take a skeleton out of a
person right you can't take a turtle out
of its shell either but if you could
you'd probably be surprised by what you
discover here's the inside of a turtle
that's Maria Wojciechowski a biologist
who's been studying turtle ecology for
more than a decade
here's your shoulder girdle here's your
hip girdle notice how those hips and
shoulders are actually inside the
turtles rib cage turtles are one of the
only land animals on the planet with
this feature they're also some of the
only animals that can breathe with their
butts you see inside a turtle shell is a
very particular respiratory system you
will see the lungs towards the top here
now most land animals breathe by
expanding and contracting their ribs
which creates a natural pump that guides
air in and out of their lungs but
turtles can't do this because they're
rigid shells don't expand so instead
they rely on sheets of muscles within
their shell to pump in oxygen through
their mouths that is most of the time
then there are other times when Turtles
breathe out the other end
more specifically through what
scientists call the cloaca it's the same
opening that Turtles used to urinate
defecate and lay eggs and in some cases
it can double as a set of gills sucking
in water and absorbing the oxygen within
scientists think that Turtles do this
they're spending long periods of time
underwater like when they're hibernating
and if you look really closely at the
inside of a shell you'd discover another
feature that helps with hibernating
underwater a scaffold like structure
that can store and release chemicals
that structure actually helps turtles
breathe without any oxygen at all it
works like this many turtles hibernate
in frozen ponds that are starved of
oxygen and to survives their metabolism
switches over from aerobic to anaerobic
that means they stop using oxygen for
energy and start using glucose instead
via a process called
anaerobic respiration and the byproduct
of that is lactic acid now theoretically
this acid could build up in a turtle's
body and kill it that's where the shells
structure comes in it can absorb the
lactic acid as well as release a
bicarbonate to neutralize that acid it's
essentially tums
but for turtles so as it turns out
having a shell is pretty handy for
certain situations in fact scientists
think that turtles originally got their
shells for digging likely more than 200
million years ago so you take like
really really complex burrowing
structures underground and of course
shells are incredibly useful for defense
against predators no matter how fierce
they may be turtles are amazing
[Music]